yesterday Anderson Cooper interviewed
future divorcee Melania Trump and asked
her what she tried to accomplish if she
becomes first lady 21st century the
social media it's very damaging for the
children we need to guide them and teach
them about social media because I see a
lot of negativity on it and we need to
have them how do you think we can put
Melania next to the Dracula candelabra
one way I'm going to combat negativity
on social media so I wonder what rain
cheese guys I wonder what you think
there's a lot of negativity on social
media what's that all about I don't know
maybe because of one of the only people
she follows just stuff like call other
people
unattractive both inside and out or a
low-class slob or a dopey clown or a
total asshole or a or they look
like or disgusting with quote nipples
protruding
I mean why Melania wait until she's
first lady to reduce negativity on
social media when she could just as
easily replace her husband's phone with
an exploding Samsung Galaxy Note 7 Ian's
given the Melania once they go after
Trump like cyberbullying what do you
think some of her other goals might be
Matthew designing grab proof women's
underwear all right points
points Jesse Joyce I don't know
something about gypsies it's impossible
to understand or I don't have a count
shockula to English dictionary all right
Carmen Lynch whatever goals Michelle
Obama has yeah